all right Tyrone what's going on hey how
you doing Mar look you know what I got
to say this man so much pain in my
soul it's so hard to let
go it's the God that I know will never
ever let me go see the pain man
I I mean I'm still lost man 56 years old
I'm still lost m i mean other day I had
little accident and you know the pain I
kind of enjoy the pain I ain't shower I
ain't did
nothing because the pain brought me
right back to where I wanted to
be I mean right back where I wanted to
pain man I mean it's like it seemed like
I was lost without it you got hit by a
car I got hit by a car man and and the
lady lady say it was my fault I broke my
collar bone and fractured my ankle you
know look at that the ankle so they gave
me a sling for the for the uh collar
bone they can't operate on that you got
to heal your they gave me a boot for for
for my fractured ankle I mean what kind
of [__] is that the police didn't ask me
nothing you know what I got racial I
ain't going to lie I thinkig because I'm
black or because I'm
homeless but the pain and you know I
didn't I went to the hospital and I Ain
pushed the issue because that pain I
kind of I kind of enjoyed that pain cuz
I ain't had that pain in so long I my
mind told me I was doing all right see
you know I'm hanging around people who
got a little little money in their
pocket so now I want to have some
money but see I started school online
now I need to keep that up now this
didn't happen I mean I mean I just want
to go hide man
now now here go the hump the hump I
never got over that
hump I'm scared to ask somebody to help
me over the
hump Mark you are wonderful man if I
asked you to help me over the hump I
know you would but you gonna give me a
hell and I don't want to hear that hell
I really don't man and see only thing
I'm used to that hell because when I was
growing up when I play basketball when
we when we messed up on the basketball
team we used to make a circle and our
coach used to take the Rings off and hit
us
in the circle everybody covered up you
couldn't see see us get hit and then
after we got hit that pain I play some
basketball so when Pop when I was going
on when pops got on my ass you ain't
going to be [__] you ain't going to
never be
[__] I kind of got up to and started
doing some
[__] I mean you know what I know a I
start thinking about Grandma Grandma
used to be like oh that that child don't
know no better mar mar leave that child
that that boy ain't got sense God gave
him I'm thinking grandma was on my side
she talking about me like a goddamn
dog and now I realize I enjoyed that
because I went around grandma just to
here talk about me and I didn't know she
was talking about me I'm thinking she
was with
me why everybody gets
me I got enough pain I can't take over
your
pain man I just want I just want to run
man see not now it's time what they say
it's not time to get out to the get
nitty-gritty and I ain't used to that
man when it's time for me to get the
nitty-gritty I go because nitty-gritty
me I need to get over that hump I don't
know how to get a hump I'm too old to
take somebody
hand you don't want to take my
hand I don't want to take nobody hand
man but I'm scared to stop learning man
I'm scared
of I figure myself out I think I know I
think I done figure myself out but I
refuse to accept
myself I refuse to accept that I ain't
[__] I ain't goingon to never be [__]
cuz I'm right here and
I I need to get over that hunt
man but the pain don't allow me to get
over that HP and man listen to songs
like I listen to songs like that man
pain in my soul uh uh
uh ain't no keep on rolling uh you can't
have one woman got to have three I mean
I already got somebody in my in my
corner I already got somebody
surrounding me so I can fall back
on I never fell back on my
own I'm scared to fall back on my own
because if I fall back I might not get
back up at least I got somebody to help
me up
and then check it out I'm going to use
that and I hate to say that because the
pain I want the self-pity I can relate
to all that
[__] why can I relate to success man
what's wrong with
success what's wrong with success man I
be around I come hang out with you
sometime Mark you
successful I ain't scared of you but I'm
get your
success I get out I get so far now I'm
trying to get a computer I'm trying to
get a labtop too for the school $30 a
month I can do that I think with the g
once a month I still be able to do
it but see I need to sacrifice some
[__] but the pain don't allow me to
sacrifice because that that void I got
in my life I got to feel that void man I
got to feel that
void Mark you want to see me take a
hit I see it's pain right here man this
pain this pain kills me man this pain
kill me man I can't look y'all got to
excuse
me it's pain man I can't hand it I can't
hand this pain
man I'll be right with you man Mark I
don't mean no dis back to you but the
pain man
now when I hit this my phone ain't
charged I us to listen to some music and
I skate skate
mentally you know what I'm saying and I
hate to say this I ain't knew what it a
it a my needs become becomes my wants H
you don't need that you want this no I
need it and want it at the same goddamn
time so don't tell me what I don't
need don't tell me no [__] like that man
I need my want is my needs without that
I ain't
[__] and they say when you take the
hdden [__] your mind separate from your
body transformation yeah we'll
see
[Music]
one lady told me before she said why do
you smoke like that she said nothing can
be that bad for you to smoke like that
but you got to understand the [__] I did
in my life I didn't did the
people D banking growing up in
Chicago luring people in vacant
houses setting people up because they
was opposition I got a lot on my mind
the [__] I've been through when I was a
kid I got a lot man so how in the
hell I can deal with this [__] look them
goddamn hookers and prostitutes or what
you want to call them I respect them
hoes cuz they got got them 50 dicks
going in their mouth in their face a day
[__] gats they don't even know and
they out there and still doing what they
doing I understand why they smoke the
way they smoke they get high the way
they get high
because the girl told me the things I do
y'all think I'm insane the things I do
the things I do keep me
sane you see I took that hit I'm cool I
ain't tweaking [__] I'm taking another
one
it's all right see that's all
right see I get a piece of mind I had to
say that it's a piece of mind I smoking
a little herb I've been smoking more
herb lately the herb I've been smoking
kind of keep me off this a little bit
cuz I'm trying to get on the herb so I
can do this school I be hiding a
[__] at night smoking herb and I
get online man I'm in my own little
world I clean my room I'm doing me ain't
nobody bother me I ain't bothering
nobody
else and that's the way I like it man I
haven't
been by myself so long when I'm with you
I'm about myself when I'm with her I'm
about myself cuz that's what I choose to
do man I was list
Tina Tina Maria
early if you live your life full of sin
when you die you come back again I
believe that I Dance with the Devil a
whole lot so I'm willing to come back I
want to come back to get a second chance
but I probably do the same goddamn thing
again because I enjoyed the pain in my
soul it's so hard to let
go and sometime I don't want to let it
go that's why I keep doing what I'm
doing does this quiet the noise that's
in your head ain't no noise in my head
cuz it's just me I skape mentally I live
a
fantasy and my fantasy that I live puts
me right where I want to be not where
you want me to be right where I want to
be it's a piece of mind and it say music
s The Savage Beast I see it goes both
way cuz I seen people jump out building
off music go crazy but music music kind
of relax me man and I get my own little
world but I got to hear certain type of
music and the music I got to hear is
pain this something I can relate to
identify
with I don't hear
no hey hey hey hey hey uh I W hear none
of
that man let me get my own little world
man let me escape mentally I enjoy
escaping and jja Vu I be looking for jja
Vu I love jja Vu because it seemed like
I've been here before but sometimes when
I get scared I hope because I've been
here before don't mean it's the end for
me cuz I don't I had dà that I was like
floating somewhere I'm scared as hell
Heights I'm scared of
heights and sometimes I feel like in my
dreams I'm falling off a building and
they say when you in hell or whatever
you call
it the holding cell it's like your
torment the torment is like what you
scared of like so I guess I keep on
falling off the building keep on falling
off the building keep on falling off the
building look I wish y'all can go come
on just kick it with me one time you
know what I'm saying throughout the day
I mean I
wish I wish y'all had time just hang out
with
me and just see what I do one day I'm
going to eat I'm going to have a ball
but I'm going get high all [__]
day all day y'all going to be like damn
how how I do that it's a part of me
that's how I do
that you go to work every day that's a
part of you this is a part of me I'm
trying man I didn't got a whole lot
better than I used to be cuz this man
here only reason I got better I got
better I ain't perfect but I got better
I start dressing excuse me cuz I I I've
been on one I ain't sh or nothing but I
I shower I change clothes I stay neat
everything cuz of this man here you do
you know better you do better but that's
not that's not necessary though cuz I
know better and I still don't do
better because IJ where I'm at man
that's a damn shame they say progress
but not
Perfection [__] I I like staying
stagnated because I ain't got to be
bothered with
nothing when I'm stagnated I can get
high I can get high I get high I can get
high and I can get
high and I ain't gota be bothered with a
goddamn thing and that's a shame 56 year
old don't want to start living I enjoy
existing but how long am I going to
exist you know this ain't goingon to
stay in my hand too long without hitting
it again come on man y'all wait I know
it ain't some of y'all can identify if
you can identify raise your hand you can
relate raise your hand if you do this
[__] raise your hand oh I see some
hands and you see that I put one hand on
here I hit
it three
T and K can't hit it again two or three
more times that's how I
smoke I make sure I have enough D on
here to last
me no you can't hit my
pipe hell no because I got dope on here
that's for me it ain't for you so I do
all this for you so I I I do I hustle I
do all this for you so I get hid to give
you what I got left so you smoke yours
now you want to smoke mine don't work
like
that unless you're a
female and I don't even like females do
that so if I hang out with a female she
got to do the opposite drug I do I only
got one smoking buddy she a white girl
love her to death she smoked more than
me and I hate
that but I hang out with her because she
understand the pain and she go do what
she do and I respect
her because I couldn't do it now that's
a soldier you got white girls out there
Philip girls they
soldiers compar what I'm doing I'm
holding to I'm holding on to the past
they they dealing with the the present
there some goddamn soldiers
man the only thing only thing I'm
dealing with present is I need to know
where my next hit from
come now I'm trying to adjust man I'm
trying to
subtitute I ain't going to hit this yet
because uh we ain't going to make this
like a crack that you know what I'm
saying because I the pain that I go
through man sometimes I be want to hurt
somebody I really do I be want to hurt
somebody because I'm hurting
if I'm hurting I want you to hurt
too but I'm lost man could you please
help
me man where can I get some help
from get on my knees get on my knees for
what when I get off my knees I'm still
going to go take a
hit man look at me man look at me I I
was I'm going
down now last time I was feeling like
this is when my bike got stolen I
depended so much on that bike I ain't
shower for 3 4 days I just laid in
bed that's a shame man when I put so
much dependence on one
thing
I this gentlem told I can't I can't
depend on him because I need to start
doing something that's why I got in
school cuz sometimes my buddy here don't
come around Mark don't come around to
help can't depend on Mark Mark don't
come CU he got his own
life and I look at him like man can I
move to Santa
Monica I mean maybe but I'm taking me
with me so I'm going to smoke crack out
there cuz I'm sure going to find
it you know we got this
thing oh he got it just nod your head I
know where it's at I see the crowds I
know where it's at I come on man I'm not
new at this I grew at this and that's a
damn shame I grew at
this 10 years old I start smoking weed 5
years old drinking the [__] I go through
yeah I need
to stuff this
[__]
man false
evidence appearing real
fear and I enjoy fear man because it
helps me get through what I fear help me
stay away from certain things when I'm
scared I don't go that
way fear fear helped me out a whole lot
fear don't believe in fear don't believe
in fear you out your goddamn mind
because I don't believe in fear I'll
probably be six feet under by now
because I'm going go into some trenches
that I don't need to go into
I kind of enjoy the negative
life I enjoy dancing with the devil
sometime cuz he helps
me I don't know because the
devil I'm not a devil worshiper don't
get that
wrong but the devil keeps you real with
me that's why I keep that that void
filled with that pain man I enjoy that
he can relate to me and I that's a damn
shame when something like that can
relate to me and he stay in my head and
I
listen
Insidious he speaks to me in my own
voice and I listen that's a damn
shame so much pain in my
soul it's so hard to let
go it's a God that I
know will never ever let me go and
that's what it says he'll never let me
go he he won't put too much on you I
mean that's why man I just got I believe
in the
universe because whatever pain I go
through in the
universe it's going to pass but I'm
going to go right back to the
pain okay I hurt myself okay weeks two
week three week four weeks whatever
everything going to heal what I'm going
do do is this is this the thing Slow Me
Down do I suppos slow down behind this
or do I keep going do I supposed to give
up behind this or do I just keep
going what I supposed to
do look
Mark I love living on on the edge man I
love
it this morning friend of man I'm up his
up his spot he listen to church music I
st crying
what this man do as F I had to take a
hit cuz now I was shedding a
tear I wasn't ready to shed no tear cuz
something getting fed that I I wasn't
expecting to get fed at that
time and he PL it and he looking at me
and he just yeah and he ain't do it and
I'm
not so I had to take one just to escape
mentally I'm not strong with this said
man I'm
strong and I'm
weak I'm a two-sided person I I'm a good
person but I'm more evil I'm more bad
than
good I don't know if that's good I don't
know if that's bad but I be me on a
daily basis and I still don't know how
to live but I know how to exist so if
they say it ain't broke don't fix it
it's broke but I don't know how to fix
it hey man I just had to come talk to
y'all for a minute get some of this off
some of this pain man you know what I'm
saying Bo I feel like
this do something man I just feel like
just man look man look man I don't I
don't know how y'all day going end up
being I don't know how my day going to
end up being you see me now I might not
be here in the next 10 minutes this
might be my last hit I
take and it might
not I guess not hey man I appre
appreciate y'all I don't mean no harm I
don't mean no disrespect to y'all
uh if your kids looking this is life
this is skit rad life people's doing the
same thing I'm doing right outside y'all
dop probably so make sure ain't no
boogeyman around cuz the kids will Hey
listen to them because the boogeyman
ain't just got to be family it could be
anybody standing on the corner hey man I
don't mean no disrespect Mark I
appreciate you man I just had to get
some off uh hey man I feel all right
better man
all right thanks man I appreciate
y'all